[Music]
Shoe Iikido, also known as Iikido SA, is
a unique style which focuses on the
practical applications of
Iikido. The founder, Fumio Sakurai
Sensei, trained in Yoshinkan Aikido
under the legendary Aikido master
Goioda. Little is known about Shu Aikido
outside of Japan, and to my
understanding, I was the first foreigner
to attend one of these seminars in about
20 years.
It was an honor to be welcomed into
their circle and for me to be able to
train with everyone
there. For those that don't know me, my
roots are in a warmer
iikido. So although most of the warm-ups
and stretching are familiar to me, some
of the exercises we did were quite
different from what I was used to.
However, everyone was patient and very
helpful in guiding me through
them. Sakurai Sensei was very
approachable and knowledgeable and took
his time explaining things and was open
to questions.
One of the most unique aspects of this
style is Iikumate, which loosely
translates as I
grappling. This is basically sparring
with live resistance whilst only using
iikido
techniques. Coming from an Lama
background, I'm already used to training
with resistance. However, this was
different as the techniques are tested
in a dynamic setting. This was a great
experience and I'll be sharing some of
my sparring footage in a future
video. Overall, I can truly say this is
one of the best Iikido seminars I've
been
to. It was a nice relaxed atmosphere and
everyone was so friendly and
supportive. Not only did many students
have significant experience in Iikido,
they also cross trainined in other
martial arts which seems to be quite
widely accepted and encouraged in this
style.
I plan to visit Japan again soon, so
hopefully I'll be able to get some more
training in and some footage whilst I'm
there. Until next time, take care.
Okay, thank you very
much. Thank you very much.